greedy big meat
my next guest spent some time working at
a meat packing plant and knows how meat
gets from the ranch to your table and
how that affects the price you pay
so here comes 1500 pounds of sweet heat
is this the loin yep that's the line
how about some uh short ribs next how
about some short ribs
so they go straight in the smokehouse
after this
do you prefer the the sweet meat or the
regular meat i like the sweet
[Music]
so much meat
[Music]
that's from his show dirty jobs on
discovery plus and he's also the author
of how america works on fox business
network and ceo mike rowe works and he
has a number one song too santa's got a
dirty job it's topping the charts right
now mike rowe
joins me so mike you know i've been in
media my whole life i've never been to a
meat processing plant like you have but
i know at least that you got
transportation costs you have
feed costs you have labor costs it's not
a bunch of greedy meat executives
thinking about how they're going to
price fix my ribeye is it
probably not look one of the first goals
of dirty jobs was to simply remind
americans of where their food comes from
yeah it's
you know there's not a meat tree in the
backyard right
all the things you just mentioned matter
and
look i
the politics of this thing are pretty
self-evident but when you really boil it
down when you're in a situation like
this
my my buddies on the left will typically
point to greed as the reason and my
friends on the right will typically
point to laziness in the human condition
at least when you're talking about the
labor shortage and make no mistake the
shortage of labor is impacting the price
of meat the price of gas the price of
everything all of this stuff is
connected you know and i i don't think
jen has much left really i mean it's
if you don't blame greed then you have
to assume the responsibility that the
policies you've put in place have
fostered a level of dependency among the
uh proletariat that's not exactly in
keeping with your uh capitalistic
virtues
so
i i guess maybe because
she might order a filet at a georgetown
steakhouse that cost 65
you know people that drive these rigs
and work in these butcher shops they
don't like people like that telling them
that you know this is the reason that's
the reason i think they know a little
bit more about supply and demand than
the white house now i want to talk to
you about some video we we saw this week
this is kamala harris our vice president
and she now wants to be in charge of
overseeing
the implementation
of
electric car charging stations across
the country
now that's not something i would
necessarily want to be in charge of
because when the federal government says
you know what we're going to put a half
a million car charging stations all over
america
i just feel like something's going to go
wrong here she is looking possible what
could possibly go
here she is this is we're going to get a
little taste of what this is going to go
like listen mike
okay that's it
there we are
that's it
and there's no sound or fume
and you can hear it you can hear the
guzzling sound right none of that
no fumes mike
no guzzling sound
now with less guzzling no look um
not not to bring it all back to me but
you know i kind of gotta the uh the
point of dirty jobs along with reminding
people of where their food came from was
to help remind people where their energy
came from and look what i'm going to
tell you right now is so basic and so
fundamental and so understood among
people in the energy business but so
completely shocking to millions of
americans and that is this the
electricity that powers that car that
she's plugging in is being generated by
turbine that turbine is spinning
somewhere i don't know where but the
odds are very very very very high
that the turbine is being powered by
natural gas
oil or coal
our electricity is tied to our fossil
fuels and if we can just get some of
these basic things lodged in our head
then we can start to see the futility of
simply solving one problem with no
regard for the unintended consequences
that are sure to follow it's a shell
game
well mapped out mike rowe
you'd think he was you know inhaling
fumes but he's not he's just like that
because that's who he is
i was just i was just guzzling because
it was just no guzzling all right thank
you mike and merry christmas
merry christmas to you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else